welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Marvel Studios first panel like
Comic-Con 2022 included major updates
for their upcoming animated titles I am
Groot what if season 2 Spider-Man
freshman year X-Men 97 and Marvel
Zombies I'm gonna break down all the new
stuff we learned about each of these
release dates characters footage
animatics connectivity to the live
action MCU and whether it's okay for
grown men to watch cartoons yes yes
let us have this okay the first of these
titles coming up is going to be I am
Groot five episodes all streaming
starting August 10th on Disney plus
let's react to this trailer here we go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
just three really
[Laughter]
I love it
[Music]
[Laughter]
they get the confetti
he's so fabulous
I mean look the animation just looks
incredible here there's gonna be any
major plot implications probably from
this show on the MCU but this just looks
like a great time it's gonna be a fun
vibe show and let's be honest a lot of
these Disney plus titles have just been
fun vibe shows and it's been fine
Bradley Cooper is confirmed to return to
Boyce rocket on this series and we were
also confirmed to get another five
episodes sometime later in the future
all right let's move on to Spider-Man
freshman year this is gonna be an
animated series in which Tom Holland is
not going to be voicing Peter Parker
it's gonna be coming 2024 which yeah is
there even going to be a world left in
2024. this is an interesting one because
it's not really clear how much it's
going to be connected to the MCU right
now it looks like it's going to be an
else world in the style of what if the
what if question and this one is what if
Peter Parker met Norman Osborne instead
of Tony Stark and we know there isn't an
Oscorp or Norman Osborne in the 616 MCU
based off of what Norman Osborne said in
Spider-Man no way home and in this
series Peter Parker is going to meet
dakak and he did not meet any Doc Ock in
this 616 continuity so imagine this is
sort of what if it's still canon in the
terms of the Multiverse and it may
reflect certain things about the 616
history but it is a separate story but
in addition to a new version of Norman
Osborne we're also gonna have Harry
Osborne in the show Charlie Cox is going
to voice Matt Murdoch Daredevil a new
look of his character we're gonna see
Nico minoru from The Runaways as well as
Amadeus show Hulk Lonnie Lincoln
Tombstone as well as scorpion Rhino
tarantula Doc Ock and several other
characters from Peter Parker's world
what I'm most excited to see are the
versions of his suit it looks like we're
going to see the DIY suits and the web
slingers before the classic Steve ditko
Style Spider-Man unitard appears and
what I really love is it looks like
there is a web fluid tank that is
attached to his backpack and yes while
season one is coming 2024 they have
already ordered a Spider-Man sophomore
year let's move on to what if season two
this is going to be streaming early 2023
so not too far away the attendees at
Hall age were able to watch a season two
episode what if Captain Carter fought
the Hydra stomper confirming many of our
theories at the end end of season 1 that
the Hydra stopper we saw inside that
tank on the ship actually did contain a
winter soldier version of Steve Rogers
that might have been corrupted by Hydra
in this section of the panel one of the
producers of what if Brian Andrews
confirmed that the version of Captain
Carter we saw in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse Madness who died was of
course not their Captain Carter there
was some footage shown that included
some interesting imagery including a
battle between Warriors from the Shang
Chi corner of the universe with the
asgardians an insane Mad Max Fury Road
style road race and some glimpses of
1602 that's the Neil Gaiman limited run
of the Marvel Comics that is set in the
year 1602 in Europe Elizabeth in England
when Stephen Strange is a physician to
the queen and the idea of magic and
Witchcraft is seen as a Superstition
everyone freaks out because superheroes
are now emerging 400 years earlier than
they do in the normal timeline so again
this is coming early 2023 and they
confirmed a season three coming sometime
after that but we all want to be
superheroes right it's not just me but
unless you're a billionaire playboy with
freaking it's engineering chops Tony
Stark Bruno just kidding you're not a
billionaire then to be a superhero you
gotta hit the gym and for me to get me
anywhere near a gym you gotta get me
motivated with at least some music in my
ears because you can't just sit me out
on that wait for with these years naked
I need a gentle hug of an earbud to lock
me into my own little safe pod where no
one can stare at me or judge how I miss
using the equipment and for me that hug
comes from some raycon Fitness earbuds
where I crank up my super Eric Mann
playlist raycon has an epic combo a
premium sound and smart Tech that helps
me go bigger than I could otherwise and
with 54 hours of battery life that is
music pumping no matter how long I am
working out for plus with their unique
earbud builds it's interchangeable gel
tips and new earbud stabilizer
attachments create three layers of
earbud personalization that means no
budge maximum Comfort stability and a
secure fit I love these and I am not
alone they've got 35 000 five-star
reviews and also probably why is Squire
voted them the best earbuds of 2021 Aid
it's not like you've got to break the
bank to get a pair raycon Fitness
earbuds are half the price of other
premium audio Brands and now is the
perfect time to pick up a pair of raycon
Fitness earbuds right now our viewers
can get them for twenty dollars off and
if you click on the link in the
description box you will unlock an
additional 15 off go to buy raycon.com
new rockstars to get access to this
limited time offer and again we thank
raycon for sponsoring this episode all
right now we gotta talk about X-Men 97
season one is coming fall 2023 as season
two has also been ordered this is going
to pick up with the fox kids X-Men
animated series from the 90s that I grew
up with and still hold close to my heart
now the big headline here is that if you
watch that series it ends with Charles
Xavier going to space so now we have a
badass looking version of Eric lyncher
Magneto leading the X-Men he's got long
swooshy hair he's jacked he's got a big
game on his chest and I can't wait to
hang out with him this costume looks
like The Uncanny X-Men number 200 era of
the character so the lineup includes the
ones you remember from that series you
got Rogue Gambit Wolverine Jubilee
Cyclops storm Gene gray and Beast
they're all standing in front of the
mansion and from what I can tell the
only difference in their looks is
Storm's hair it swooshes up it's short
it looks great and she doesn't need
hairspray she uses the great powerful
Wings I'm serious it would be hilarious
if she just had like little gusts of
wind just puffing it up I mean I wish I
had that now in addition to these uh we
see a lineup of some other characters
that include Nightcrawler Forge morph
Bishop cable and Sunspot which is
interesting because Sunspot was not in
the original 90s run the villains are
what we can see include Mr Sinister
Kalisto Sebastian Shaw White Queen and
Val Cooper Val Cooper apparently has an
agenda that will be revealed throughout
the season but Robert de Mayo says
there was an animatic shown at the panel
that includes the X-Men alongside more
fighting Sentinels Rogue tears the head
off of a sentinel throws into another
Sentinel with the classic it's a line
apparently Disney plus is going to
adjust some continuity errors from the
original 90s run so the Jean Gray
doesn't just mysteriously reappear I'm
super excited for this one again coming
fall 2023. all right now let's move on
to Marvel Zombies this is being written
by Zeb Wells a loose adaptation of
Robert kirkman's Marvel Zombies Comics
which Loosely inspired the episode of
what if season one in which several of
the characters were zombified so this is
going to follow a ragtag group of Heroes
that include some surprising faces you
got shangchi you get Elena biloba Jimmy
woo in a surprising survivalist outfit
you got Kate Bishop you got Kamala Khan
you got Katie from sunshi you got Red
Guardian from Black Widow and he got
death dealer from Chi all these Heroes
banding together to fight a lineup of
zombified Marvel heroes that include
Okoye Hawkeye with a bunch of arrows
sticking out of him Abomination with an
interesting form of zombification on his
body we got zombie Captain America with
no legs zombie Captain Marvel zombie
Wanda maximoff looks like zombie ghost
remember we don't know what happened to
ghost after Ant-Man and the WASP there's
also a giant looming figure maybe a
zombie giant man or a zombie Thanos or a
zombie Hulk and there's several zombies
with Spears behind them it looks like
one of the settings may be zombie
wakanda as we saw in the final moments
of that what if Episode there's also a
shot of a pseudo zombie Icarus who
because he's an eternal cannot become a
full zombie he's just constantly in a
state of dying and living which is how I
really feel in a constant state of dying
and living we're always slowly dying
we're also slowly living glass apple
glass at empty you decide Marvel Zombies
will Premiere sometime in 2024. so those
are all the major headlines coming out
of Marvel Studios first panel covering
their animated titles new rock stars
throughout this weekend we'll be doing a
mix of coverage we're gonna have live
episodes of the break room that cover
this information as it drops and reacts
to it in real time that includes the big
headlines that are going to come during
Marvel Studio goes live action title
panel where we're gonna get updates
about Black Panther wakanda forever and
a number of the Disney Plus shows so be
sure to tune in Live 5 p.m Pacific
tomorrow Saturday July 23rd for that
live coverage and after that panel is
done I'm gonna have another one of these
quick reaction Recaps that just
summarizes all the big takeaways be sure
to subscribe to new rockstars follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars thank you for watching and
I'll see you tomorrow bye
[Music]